exhausted
and at sea for days with no way of
knowing when their Journey will end
for the past week this overcrowded
rescue ship has been sailing in
international waters near Sicily with no
permission to land
and those saved from the sea getting
more desperate as supplies run out and
Facilities break down
as you can see there are so many of us
nearly 600 people women old people and
children we don't have enough space to
sleep we are sleeping down on the floor
and it's very cold at morning and at
night actually the situation is becoming
death today more difficult the team and
the ship they do whatever they can they
give us all the resources that they've
got but it's difficult for them
almost 1 000 people including more than
100 unaccompanied minors are currently
on board three humanitarian rescue ships
operated by European ngos
yet there's been no answer to the
requests for help from the countries
nearest to them
we already stand before four different
requests or place of safety to Malta and
actually we already sent two requests
from uh to the Italian Authority and we
did only receive the formal reply that
the our request has been forward to the
competent Authority which is the
Minister of interior
the challenge lies in convincing Italy's
new right-wing-led government its prime
minister Georgia Maloney has made it a
priority to stop migrant boat Landings
putting former interior Minister Matteo
salvini in charge of ports as the new
infrastructure minister
salvini himself is facing charges of
kidnapping after he prevented 147 Asylum
Seekers from disembarking back in 2019.
Milani's Hardline rhetoric on NGO
vessels has not changed putting her on a
collision course with other European
union members
with worsening weather conditions on
their way those trapped at Sea remain
Pawns in Europe's continuing debate of
immigration Sony Gallego Al Jazeera